fbi director christopher wray is
comparing the recent cyber attacks to
the september 11th
attacks in a new wall street journal
interview he also said the agency is
investigating about a hundred different
types of ransomware that's software that
holds information
for ransom and much of it is traced back
to hackers
in russia all of it comes as the
department of justice says it will now
handle the attacks on the world's
largest meat processing company and
colonial pipeline
as acts of terrorism jeff begave joins
us jeff good morning to you so clearly
our government is making this a high
priority
why so yeah tony u.s officials know that
this list of ransomware attacks
it will continue to get longer in a
letter to federal prosecutors across the
country yesterday deputy attorney
general lisa monaco said that the
department
must make sure that its efforts to
combat digital extortion
are focused coordinated and
appropriately resourced
she said the doj must enhance and
centralize the tracking of
investigations
and prosecutions of ransomware groups
also
white house officials issued an
extraordinary warning to american
companies
urging business leaders to take
immediate steps to
increase cyber security because quote no
company
is safe both of the recent ransomware
attacks on colonial pipeline and jbs
have been linked to criminal hacking
groups likely based in russia
president biden is expected to raise the
issue when he meets with russian
president vladimir putin later this
month these hacking groups
have stolen hundreds of millions of
dollars and that
may be gail an underestimate of the
financial cost of all this
all right jeff thank you very much